a crime scene that has become all too
familiar for journalists across mexico
lordes maldonado lopez had been targeted
before for doing her job but this time
she didn't survive
gunmen shot her as she waited in a car
in tijuana's santa fe neighborhood
police received a call but it was too
late when they arrived at the scene
the secretary of security and citizen
protection had the responsibility to
continue to offer security to lourdes
maldonado she'd said that when she'd
arrive home in the evenings it was when
she felt most vulnerable she did not
have that protection
lopez is the second journalist to be
killed in mexico in less than a week and
the third this month alone on monday
another journalist margarito martinez
who covered police and crime stories was
also killed
the committee to protect journalists has
called on mexico to investigate the
attack thoroughly and transparently
the brutal reality of mexico nowadays is
that the federal state and the municipal
government simply don't investigate the
crimes against the population in general
or against human rights activists and
journalists
in 2019 lopez told mexican president
andres manuel lopez obrador she'd feared
for her life and asked for support it
followed a labor dispute where she sued
an influential former employee for
unfair dismissal a lawsuit she won a few
days ago
it is very painful what happened in
tijuana we will soon investigate she was
indeed here in the beginning of 2019 to
make a complaint about the labor issue
and she was assisted unfortunately this
happened we need to see if this
assassination is connected to the labor
issue or not and find who is responsible
mexico is one of the most dangerous
countries for journalists more than 100
media workers have been murdered in the
last couple of decades but only a
fraction of those crimes have led to
convictions
al jazeera